jusque dans les années 80 voilà à quoi
ressemblait une inscription à la fac
cette nuit à tolbiac comme chaque année
se sont formés les traditionnels files
d'attentes de bacheliers en herbe ou de
parents décider qui avait préféré campé
là pour avoir au moins une chance
d'obtenir un dossier des heures
d'attentes pour espérer une place dans
l'université de son choix
un parcours du combattant qui a donné
lieu à quelques lapsus et c'est alors
pour cent mille d'entre eux que commence
la course contre la mort l'amour et il
valait mieux être à l'heure car la règle
était la même pour tout le monde
premier arrivé premier servi
il ya nombre de places n'y a pas une
note on n'a pas la mention rien de rien
si le bac c'est souvent
alors forcément pour les retardataires
c'était souvent un choix par dépit
l'edl de droit et dans les trucs comme
ça y est j'ai des coûts de 400 personnes
alors on a préféré venir s'inscrire ici
on dessine dès la rentrée 90 fini la
collante place aux 36 14 code ravel un
dispositif réservé aux franciliens
objectif réguler le flux étudiants en
région parisienne avec le système ravel
et lycéens doivent formuler trois voeux
d'inscription en fac
ce recensement des voeux des élèves
permet aux universités de gérer au mieux
le nombre des places disponibles cette
année 90 % des lycéens devraient s'être
connecté sur havel après le minitel le
dispositif basculait sur internet dans
les années 2000 plus de files d'attentes
devant les universités certes mais des
embouteillages virtuel la sorbonne
quotas d'où la deuxième en 2009 pour
plus de fluidité place un autre
dispositif pour les futurs étudiants
rendez vous désormais sur apb pour
admission postbac
le serveur qui enregistre la quasi
totalité des inscriptions depuis l'an
dernier à prix fixe était 24e possible
par candidat contre trois sur abel plus
de choix plus de modernité elle est
toujours le même refrain
j'ai perdu c'est un peu à part contre
combattants commun à la rentrée 2010 est
la dernière d'apb trois mille bacheliers
s'était retrouvé sans affectation
[Musique]